Karla is with us in Las Vegas hi Karla
how are you good how are you better than
I deserve
what's up well I have to say about that
every dollar so we were on the brink of
filing bankruptcy a few years ago and we
were just like in bad straits use the
every dollar tool and we're able to turn
our whole life around and try to teach
our children to wait for what they
really want and that every day is a
blessing and to find the good and
everything other than just anything
financial oh look for you way to go we
are only in debt to our house and we
went recently from a thirty year to a 15
years rocking on yeah we're good we're
good I my husband's family and my family
we would never like that we were raised
like this and so my husband and I were
both on board and how can I help today
well we have a 16 year old our oldest
one we have several children but our
oldest one he is starting to work and I
almost want to say she jumped on board
to the extreme he is working part-time
he within a month got promoted he's not
working you know he started off minimum
wage and now is not minimum wage and got
a promotion and a pay raise and only
wants to put all his money in a savings
account and I tell and he like friends
will ask him to go do stuff and he's
like no no I can't do it why what cause
it costs money like well you're like
almost 70 you're like you're 16 go enjoy
yourself like go enjoy your life - okay
here's what I would say if I were you
and probably at 16 houses relationship
with his dad amazing I have an amazing
husband we're going to be married next
year next month it'll be 19 years Wow
okay here's what I want your husband
there i am to sit on the back porch with
this young man and talk not dad to belt
boy but father to man and here's what it
sounds like
okay um son I'm so proud of you you're
picking up the things that we learned
late and you're working hard and you're
good at work and you're good at saving
money and those are attributes that as a
man they're going to serve you well
so as you're growing into manhood I'm
proud of the progress you've made
okay first we're going to affirm the two
things he's doing very well
he's a good kid okay he's an amazing kid
and that you need to say that out loud
because they don't hear it loud and
clear unless you say it a lot
when they're 16 because they got a lot
of other voices out there okay so this
is dad - son on the back porch nobody
else is there okay all right and first
we affirm those two things and then we
say as your dad it is my job to walk
with you the rest of the way in the
manhood and to make sure you are
prepared to live a very high-quality
life as a man and that involves enjoying
money saving money giving money and
working for money you need to be able to
do all of those things to be a complete
adult you need to be able to enjoy money
give money save money and work for money
so the good news bye-bye is you got two
out of three doing real well now you and
I are going to work together to help you
become generous with some of your money
and giving and you and I are going to
work together and I'm going to observe
you enjoying some of your money but Dad
I just want to save it all I know but
that's what a boy would do a man enjoys
the whole process you enjoy some you
give some you save some and you work for
all of it and if you couch it that way
your husband is helping your son walk
into adulthood
and and and there's a special thing that
could happen right there between them in
a culture that has forgotten manhood no
and that's true my husband and my son
both have such a strong bond in many
ways and I think it's just um but we all
we all are natural givers savers or
spenders and your son is a natural saver
and so he has to also and learn to enjoy
money otherwise he'll make a miserable
husband because his wife won't have much
of a life okay and he also has to learn
to be generous because that changes his
heart and it's part of his spiritual
walk so you just talked him through that
and here's the good news you don't have
to talk about it but one time and then
you just course correct when he's off
base a little bit and it goes back to
that back porch conversation that one
time because it'll be so poignant for
him as a father and so on sudden
movement that he will remember it the
rest of his life he'll tell his
grandkids about his old man sitting on
the back porch guiding him and how do I
be a man on how to handle money it'll be
that big a deal if he does it the way
I'm talking about and you know my son
and I have had a lot of wonderful
experiences that way and we are really
good friends and we're both adults now
and to this day but we walk together
through the teenage years and through
those last few years of learning um we
didn't just turn him loose like he was
raised by wolves to do whatever his
instinct and passions told him to do and
we weren't overbearing we didn't race
Stepford children we had children that
messed up and did all kinds of things
that other kids do too but we're going
to walk into a process that leads us to
become the adult that we want to become
I'm not trying to raise great kids I'm
trying to raise kids that become great
adults that's my friend Andy Andrews
line and it is a beautiful description
of what we're talking about so hold on
I'm going to send you guys out a copy of
smart money smart kids which is the book
Rachael and I did on how to teach your
kids of any age how to handle money
because if you don't teach your kids how
to handle money
they'll end up living in your basement
and we all know an eagle that doesn't
leave the nest is eventually known as a
turkey hi so hold on Wilson give you a
copy of smart money smart kids I don't
predict that for this kid this kid's
gonna be rich we just got to teach him
to enjoy and be generous and that'll be
easy to teach him so he's a good kid and
you're blessed you're blessed family
Carla hold on and Kelly will pick up and
we'll get you signed up for all of that
hey you guys Rachel Cruise here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than the dayroom 2
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you